did you really have no idea what you
were going to write down for the
Armageddon like we were all out there
discussing if it was genius if you wrote
10 cuz you knew he was going to bid 958
or but then you answered like I had no
clue I just wrote something and yeah I
was just pissed after the
game I I had no idea what to write
really so
uh I did like the most my brain was able
to process with that he wrote like 958
or something or 9 no no sorry like 10 1
or 102 or something yesterday so I
thought I'd go a few seconds lower which
is like the most basic it's like if your
opponent
did um rock the last time you'll do
paper you think you'll do it again so
yeah uh no there was not much thought
into it but I've been I mean I've been
struggling so hard with black today that
I yeah that I thought I'm I was not
unhappy to to play White